la ciudad Palestina dona Blue sufrió
anoche en las horas más violentas que se
han registrado este año en cisjordania
ocupada todo comenzó sobre la una de la
mañana con la irrupción de un convoy de
vehículos israelíes formados por
soldados y agentes de inteligencia del
chimbet y prosiguió con explosiones y
disparos hasta que Israel siempre según
la prensa Palestina lanzó misiles
antitanque el ejército israelí no
precisó el Cómo o la manera pero anunció
que logró destruir un edificio
supuestamente usado como taller de
explosivos por la nueva milicia lions en
la guarida de los leones que era sin
duda el objetivo de las fuerzas
israelíes Aunque Israel lleva meses
realizando redadas que tilda de contra
terrorismo los cinco muertos de esta
noche con un sexto adicional en ramala
son algo excepcional este último fue un
joven de 19 años que murió de un disparo
israelí mientras que del resto de
fallecidos en nablue solo uno ha sido
reivindicado como cabecilla de la
milicia sobre toda esta operación que
hirió también a 20 intestinos habló el
Primer Ministro interino Yair lapiz que
felicitó a las fuerzas israelíes por
eliminar a un jefe de la milicia y
asestar un duro golpe al terrorismo todo
lo contrario el portavoz del presidente
palestino más mutabas calificó la redada
de crimen de guerra debido a esto hoy se
ha vuelto a extender una huelga
Palestina en cisjordania contra estas
redadas israelíes que han generado más
de 2.000 arrestos y 132 muertos la cifra
más alta desde 2015 desde la antifaz de
los cuchillos Justo a una y precaución
en hablar de una potencial nueva
interfaz pero la violencia que es diaria
en cisjordania recuerda mucho a esos
días que también se dan a las puertas de
las elecciones de Israel este 1 de
noviembre